foreign
[Applause]
I really like the movie too and I don't
really I'm really hard on film so yeah
what was it like filming the movie did
you guys because
um it's so terrifying
um to ever do or say the wrong thing
yeah I'm afraid to get cancer and this
film is an incredible breath of fresh
air just finding comedy and heart in
very difficult places for sure and I
think that's what makes the film so
special because comedy is medicine and I
think that it's a really amazing way to
bring on these really hard conversations
it's a really great way to bring on
awareness to these conversations and for
all of us to be you know just sensitive
to our differences accepting our
differences you know respecting our
differences and it's every five seconds
I was laughing in this movie
watching it and I'm not gassing it up
like I really enjoyed this movie it is
so it's really funny guys now okay
you're making it with Kenya Barris who
did blackish and grown-ish I mean I
think people consider him or like I
think I consider them a very uh
Hollywood royalty type of person what
um does it feel safer like when it's
with someone that you really trust and
respect absolutely also because I'm very
apprehensive with just
working right now just grieving still
and just you know
building a new life so I'm very
intentional on who I work with and Kenya
just created a really safe space and so
did Jonah just a really really safe
space for me to play
to be new in this environment you know
I've been recently saying this is a new
pool that I'm swimming in so can get
knowing him trusting him and respecting
him really helped just now you mentioned
that you've been through a lot and that
it took a lot to consider sort of
working right now you've been so open
about it I'm a mother of two daughters
you're the mother of two sons yes and I
love the way that you talk about your
sons I'm obsessed with them I'm forever
I'm obsessed with my kids they're the
coolest I love them so much they are
such a big part of why I get up in the
morning and have hope and joy because
they deserve so much love and joy so
they're just they don't even know that
they are my angels and they encourage
you to go back to work my eldest
definitely does the little one is like
stay home cook and be on call for me
right
he's like Ma'am why do you have to go to
work and why do I have to go to school
if it was up to him we'd live on an
island and just figure it out but the
oldest one is like you're going to work
you're oh yeah like he's so excited for
me and just he likes to see me on TV I
think he just likes to see movement how
did you find the courage to go back to
work because you have been through yeah
and I wonder sometimes when people's
lives are forever altered how do they
get up in the morning how do they go on
with their day how do you do it every
day is different and so some days you
don't want to you just want to lay there
my big reason is my children because
they do deserve a really happy mom and
they deserve joy and they deserve a
house that has music playing and
instance going and light coming in the
windows and they deserve that and you
know when you lose someone you know
they're on the other side wanting you to
continue life as well
so I just always think about what I know
nip would want me to do and what I know
my children deserve and what I deserve
too and for context nipsy hustle is
someone that you know everyone lost
because he passed away but he was your
person and you know you said comedy is
medicine sometimes it's being able to
laugh and sometimes it's being able to
Drudge up strength that you didn't think
you had in honor of your child and it's
you know you have so many tools out here
to help us we just have to
recognize what they are music is a big
healing tool nature food and those are
good prompts yes you know like if you're
feeling a certain way like eat the thing
you want to eat
well that's my issue Drew I eat too much
of what I want to eat sometimes me too
because honey that's I need to slow it
down sometimes that's what I need I work
out what's about having Grace with you
balance whatever I'm trying it's about
Grace listen we all have gone through
stuff life is tough on all of us we're
all human and life has gone to life you
know what I mean it's also about are you
gonna let life take you or you're going
to take life and so I and I don't mean
take life but I mean like it might go by
the you know what I can't just live it
right yes absolutely we're gonna cut to
a quick commercial break but I would
love some of your suggestions because
we're all looking for prompts in life of
things to do or go to or be aware of so
um will you do three to go with us for
your suggestions we'll be right back
[Music]